let's talk a little bit about one of the
what i find to be one of the more
mysterious forces of the universe
actually i find all of the forces of the
universe to be fairly mysterious so
let's talk a little bit about charge
and we've all heard of charge
you know charge the battery you know
this particle has charge
but when you really think about it all
charge means is
that there's this property called charge
and and we know that if you know
something contains a positive charge and
calling it positive is a little bit
arbitrary it's not like protons have a
little plus written on them we could
have called them negative but that when
something has a positive charge and when
something else has a positive charge
that they repel each other
and we also know that if if i had
something else another particle that
happened to have a negative charge and
once again the word negative being
applied to this is is completely
arbitrary they could have called it a
blue charge and red charge but all we
know is that when another object has
the other charge in this case we call it
negative that's going to be attracted to
a positive charge
right so what do we know about charge
charge is a property that particles have
and if you put enough particles together
i guess objects have that property as
well
so it's just a property
and that's that's a that's a way of
saying that i really don't know what it
is and and frankly no one fundamentally
knows what it is actually no one really
fundamentally knows anything
but charge is a property of particles
and objects just like mass i mean if you
think about it
mass is just a property and to some
degree it seems a little bit more real
than charge because
in in you know our brains are wired to
in some way comprehend what mass is
but we're probably more
comprehending weight and volume more
than mass but we can think more about
that at another time
charge is a little bit more abstract
because
before we started rubbing amber into our
hair
we really didn't experience much charge
unless we got struck by lightning
so charge is a property that that
particles or objects have and we know
that there are two types of charge which
we've arbitrary
arbitrarily
named positive and negative and we know
that like charges
like charges
repel
and opposite charges
opposite charge
attracts or unlike charges attract
all right
so what can we do with this well if we
if we have this property i think a
useful
thing to do would be to measure the
property and so we came up with units
and so the unit of charge is called the
coulomb
it's named after a scientist in the late
1700s who played around a lot with
charge you can look look up more about
him and on wikipedia but it's called the
coulomb
and the coulomb there's a bunch of
definitions but
i like to think of it in terms of
elementary particles uh just because
to some degree well unless you go start
going to you know quantum theory and
start talking about quarks and stuff
the elementary charge is the charge on a
proton or a neutron
so i'll go into more detail in the
future on actually the structure of
atoms and whatever else but let me just
draw a little example so you know
a a atom tends to have some neutrons in
them which don't have this charge
property it'll have some protons in them
which have a positive charge and once
again that's kind of
arbitrarily defined as positive we could
have called it it has a red charge
and then it has these things floating
around that are much lighter than the
much much much lighter than the uh than
the protons and the neutrons in the
nucleus
and these are called electrons
it's not even clear today that they're
real objects they're almost they're
almost um they're almost like energy but
sometimes it's useful to view them as as
objects sometimes it's useful to view
them as
as
well not as objects and we'll go into
all of that more later
but electrons have a negative charge
and the fundamental unit of charge as
far as we are concerned right now before
we start talking about quarks and other
potentially subatomic particles is the
charge in an electron or a proton and
they have the exact same charge
and and that elementary charge is
denoted by e and to be frank i'm not
sure whether e stands for elementary or
e stands for electron but actually e is
equal to the charge of a proton so it
probably stands for elementary
charge
of a proton
and the charge of a nega of an electron
is the negative of this so negative e is
the charge of an electron
charge of
electron
but if we didn't carry carry about size
about sine
then the magnitudes are the same so
that's the fundamental
as far as we know or so far in our
physics that's the fundamental charge
the fundamental unit of charge is just
the
the charge in a proton or neutron so how
does a coulomb relate to that well a
coulomb which we'll denote by c
is equal to and this is a bit of a
arbitrary number
but when we start doing things with
electricity we'll see
why the coulomb was defined the way it
is but a coulomb is
6.24 times
10 to the 18th ease
or you could say it's 6.24 times 10 to
the 18th times the charge on an electron
actually times the charge on a proton
and then of course
in terms of magnitude because you know
if i just say coulomb i'm not really
giving a direction
so if you look at the other way around
you can say that the elementary charge
the elementary charge is equal to at
least its magnitude
1.6 times 10 to the minus 19
coulombs
so fair enough this might be a useful
number to memorize but it it will
usually be provided for you in some way
so what can we do we've we've we say
that these objects have this property
called charge like charges repel unlike
charges attract
if we have enough of these uh protons
if together then the whole object has
charge
if if we have more let's say protons and
electrons and we have a positive charge
if we have more electrons and protons we
have a negative charge
and and we know that we've defined this
unit of charge called the coulomb which
is a bunch of
the fundamental charge so let's play
around with this and see if we can
measure charge
so
in in part of the initial i guess we
could call a definition on on what
charge is i said that um
that like charges repel right like
charges repel so those both of these are
positive they're going to repel each
other
and unlike charges if this is negative
this is positive they're going to
attract each other right
so
by definition if they are moving each
other there you know these two particles
are going to accelerate away from each
other these two particles are going to
accelerate towards each other
the charge between these particles or
the charge in each of these particles
must be generating some type of force
right if there was no force being
generated then they wouldn't repel or
attract each other
and this is where we get to coulomb's
law and this is why we name charges
after coulomb
coulomb figured out that
the force
between two charges
is equal to and this is going to be a
vector quantity and all in about 30
seconds i'll tell you which you know
what happens with the direction is equal
to some constant
times the first charge
times the second charge
divided by the distance between them
squared
and this is pretty neat because this
looks an awful lot like so if we call
this the the force
the electric force
that looks a lot like the gravitational
force equation let me write that down
the force from gravity between two
masses
is equal to the gravitational constant
times m one
times m 2 divided by the distance
between them squared
so so far the two forces that we've
covered gravity and now we're covering
electric force and we'll eventually
expand this to electromagnetic force it
seems like you know they they kind of
act at distance in a similar way and
both of these forces apply into gravity
in a vacuum so it doesn't matter if you
have no air if you have no substances
between the two particles somehow they
are communicating with each other which
i find kind of amazing right you can
have nothing between these two particles
but somehow this particle knows that
that particle's there and that particle
knows that that particle's there and
they start moving
without having any you know it's not
like they have a wire connecting to each
other and someone's telling the other
particle hey there's a particle there
start moving so i don't know if you find
that as amazing as i do but but think
about it and you might and it's just
like gravity i mean the two masses there
are no way connected they could be
sitting in a vacuum but somehow they
know that the other particle is there
and when we start learning about
special relativity and all of that we'll
learn that oh maybe you know there's
nothing there but maybe the masses are
actually somehow shaping the universe
and maybe that's happening with with the
electric charges as well
but all we know at this point is that we
have these charges and that they exert a
force on each other that's proportional
to the product of their of their
respective charges divided by
the square of the distance between them
and this constant right here
that is
i always forget it what was it i think
it's uh
six point
i always forget what that constant is
it is
nine times ten to the ninth
it's okay that that's a it's rounded of
course that would be amazing if it was
exactly nine
nine times
ten to the ninth
and the units are newton
meter squared
per coulomb squared and why are the new
why are those
the units
well pretty much because
at the end we have
we have coulomb coulombs we're going to
have coulomb squared divided by meter
squared and we want to finish with
newtons so we want to cancel out the
coulomb squared by putting in the
denominator we want to cancel out the
meter square by putting in the numerator
and then we'll end up with the newtons
to get the force so that's just where
the units come from so given that let's
figure out the force between two
particles so let's say i have
i have and you know i've spent 10
minutes with a pretty long-winded
explanation but the actual problems
you'll see in your in your physics class
are pretty straightforward when it comes
to
coulomb's law so they'll say hey you
know we have a
a positive
we have a particle here that has a
positive charge of let's call it i don't
know
plus
let me think of a good number um
i don't know plus 5
times
to the
minus 3 coulombs so that's a positive
charge and then we have a negative
charge here
and let's say that
i don't know how far how far will i make
them let's say that they're
half a meter apart 0.5 meters apart and
then i have a negative charge here that
is
let's say that this is 10
minus 10
times
10 to the
i don't know minus 2 coulombs
so what is the force between these two
particles so if we just plug them into
coulomb's law we get
the electric the force
do the electricity due due to
the electrical force not due to
electricity we haven't done that yet the
static electric force between those two
particles is equal to
the constant 9 times 10 to the ninth
nine times 10 to the ninth
times the first charge times five
times ten to the minus three times the
second charge let me do that different
color
times
minus ten
times ten
to the minus 2. i just rewrote that
although you probably can't see it
divided by the distance squared so 0.5
squared
we just plugged into this formula
so that equals let me see so 9 times 0.5
times 10 i'm just going to
do the 10 separately so that's times
minus 10. so it's minus
this is
0.5 times minus 10 is minus 5 times 9 is
minus 45
and then 10 to the ninth
minus 3 so 10 to the sixth and then
minus 2 so 10 to the fourth times
10 to the fourth
divided by and what's 0.5 squared is
0.25
right and this is equal to what that's
equal to 4 times this top 160 plus this
is equal to minus 180
times
to the fourth
newtons
and actually this might seem like a
large number but these charges that i
put here are actually fairly large
charges and will hopefully you'll get a
sense for um what's a bigger small
charge later but these are reasonably
large charges and so that's why there's
a relatively large force exerting
between these two particles now we got a
negative number so what does that mean
well we know that unlike particles
attract right almost by definition in
this case we had a positive and negative
so when we have a negative
when we end up with a negative force
when we use coulomb's law that means
that the force will draw the two
particles to each other along their the
shortest distance between them i mean
it's not like it's not going to make
them go in a curve it kind of makes
sense if we had a positive there that
that means that the force was repelling
the two particles and if you ever get
confused just think about it if they're
both negative they're going to repel
they're both positive they're going to
attract
i will see you in the next video